Healthcare is the most information
intensive industry in the economy and it
uses information technology,
the least of any industry in the
economy,
so if you think about where do we need
information to most,
it's currently healthcare.
You need to know what's going on with
the patient,
what they're allergic to,
what kinds of issues they have,
what treatment options,
and yet we still do things by paper and
pencil,
storing things in huge stacks where you
can't retrieve them and they're not
there where you need them.
Healthcare is amongst the lowest
productivity industries in the economy.
If you look at the well performing
industries,
they tend to have three features.
The productive industries tend to have
three features.
First,
they use information technology a lot.
They know who's doing what,
why they're doing it,
how rapidly they're doing it,
what the outcome is,
how to improve it.
They're always thinking about that.
They use information technology a lot.
In healthcare,
we don't.
Second,
they have compensation arrangements that
are tied to improving value.
When employees create value,
they get paid more when when they do
things that don't create value,
that they don't get paid as much.
In healthcare,
you get paid for doing things for volume
but not for value,
and third is they.
They decentralize it so that changes are
made by workers.
Workers have authority.
The famous Toyota model,
any worker can stop the production line.
Why?
Because he or she has the right
information and the right incentives to
make sure that the cars are coming out
with the quality that they need to.
In healthcare.
The frontline workers are so busy just
getting by that they don't have the
opportunity to do better.
If you take those nurses who are
spending a third of their time
documenting things and say,
well,
couldn't we do better?
They'd say yes,
but I just don't have the time to figure
out how I'm so rushed.
I can't figure it out.
Healthcare has got to get better.
It's got to get better on the
information and where we've made a good
start with the recent American recovery
and reinvestment act,
which is spending $30,
million dollars on health it
compensation changes,
which you need to follow that hopefully
in healthcare legislation that comes
this fall that will say we pay more for
value and not just for volume.
An organization changes,
freeing up organizations and helping
them learn from each other so that they
say,
hey,
you know what?
I really can make this a high performing
enterprise.
This doesn't have to be an enterprise
that's got low productivity.
It come back to the most productive
businesses,
the ones that have increasingly lower
costs.
Those are businesses that are actually
the most innovative,
not the least innovative.
If you look at the most productive
industries in the economy,
their industries like information
technology,
like retail trade,
like agriculture that use technology
than most,
but they direct it the right way for
people think that healthcare reform is
going to involve stifling.
Innovation is just absolutely wrong.
If we do it right,
we're going to open the possibilities
for enormous amounts of innovation.
We just give you a different example
than what we've seen.
Take a take an antidepressant.
Drugs,
just as one example,
it is a well known fact that
antidepressant drugs,
the same drug will work on some patients
and not work on others is give,
give people paxil or give people a
Prozac or give them selects or whatever
it is.
Some patients respond to it,
other patients out,
and it's different.
Some people respond to one medication,
some people respond to another,
some people respond to a third but not
to the others.
Why is that?
Well,
we don't know.
There's surely something biological
about it.
When you switch people from one drug to
another,
you,
you wind up,
uh,
sometimes,
getting them to respond to getting
better,
well with a little bit of innovation
will be able to figure out which
patients will respond better to which
drugs.
As a result,
we can avoid giving people drugs.
They're not going to respond to wasting
money,
wasting treatment.
The people don't come back because the
thing is not working.
Even worse with some kind of
chemotherapy agents where the patient
dies in the interim with innovation will
be able to figure out how to tailor what
you need once you get to what you need
in addition to all the other things
we're talking about,
so we'll have the medical care system
that's actually customized for you,
not just for something generic,
not just,
hey,
we just start on this because this is
what we do,
and if you don't respond better,
it's your responsibility for figuring
out how to do something different.
That's just one example of where we're
going to need a lot of innovation.
Healthcare reform has to encourage
innovation across the board or else it's
not going to say.